[inaudible]
let me start with question.
Where do you think there is more
inequality?
Is it in silicon valley or isn't in
Burundi?
Exactly.
The answer of course is silicon valley.
This is not actually necessarily bad
news.
For example,
imagine that you work as a systems
engineer at the Cisco officers in San
Jose.
You can make around $7,500 a month.
Not Bad.
Right?
Well,
if you could go that with your friends
who works as a software engineer at
Google,
you're going to feel like a beg APP.
Somebody in that position can easily
make more than $11,000 a month.
And of course all of that is pretty much
pennies if you compare it to the
earnings of your neighbors,
Elon Musk and mark Zuckerberg or any of
the other tycoons sniffing in the area.
In other words,
anybody would feel poor living amongst
the people with the world's largest
fortunes and yes,
I can guess we were thinking,
I mean it surely it's not so bad to live
in a city where people are making
$150,000 a year on average.
All right,
so I can probably guess where you're
thinking right now.
You're probably thinking,
well,
living in the city web poor people make
$150,000 a year is going to be a pretty
good place to live,
right?
Well,
yes,
but as we say,
things aren't always as good as they see
in an area with so much concentrated
wealth.
Well,
what do you think happens?
Yup.
Prices go absolutely.
Sky High.
For example,
how much do you think you'd have to pay
to rent a two bedroom apartment in
mountain view?
Mountain view,
by the way,
is where Google has his headquarters and
do note here.
We're not talking about a big metropolis
like New York City or London.
This town's population would fit
comfortably in the middle of somewhere
like,
oh yeah.
All right,
so that being said,
how much do you think you should pay
$500 a month,
$1,000 a month,
$2,000 a month?
Well after several google searches,
the cheapest rent we could find was
$3,400 the cheapest in general houses in
Silicon Valley are 60% more expensive
than elsewhere in America.
And I know,
I know with a salary of $11,000 a month
for your more than happy to pay $3,500 a
month in rent.
Right?
Well,
absolutely.
But let's just think for a moment.
We've got to think about,
well,
what Silicon Valley really famous for,
and it's famous for entrepreneurs.
The main appeal of Silicon Valley is not
working for facebook.
It's for starting your own facebook.
So now think about it.
What do you really want to start a
company in such an expensive place?
Maybe knots,
which explains this.
The tech
elite are abandoning silicon valley in
droves because of group think and out of
control.
Living costs.
Yeah,
you have that right.
In the year 2017 silicon valley had
negative net for the first time in
decades.
This means there were more people
leaving than coming in,
and this is surprising if we take into
account that this area of the world was
growing like crazy since the year 1950
take mountain view.
For example,
in 1950 this town was no bigger than
6,000 inhabitants.
Now it has more than 81,000 and the same
map and with the rest of the area.
Nonetheless,
according to a survey,
half of the residents are seriously
considering leaving because of the high
cost of living.
Some of them have already left and among
them is the man you see here.
Teal leaves Silicon Valley for Los
Angeles and guys you've never heard of
him.
He gtl is something like Silicon
Valley's Santa Claus along with Elon
Musk.
He's one of the founders of paypal.
After that,
he became a venture capitalist and we'd
say he's basically facebook's godfather
please.
Steve was the one who put serious money
into this company when it was taking its
first baby steps,
but the question now is why are there so
many people leaving Silicon Valley?
Is the cost of living really the only
reason or are there others?
And most importantly,
is this the end of Silicon Valley as we
know it?
Well today we're going to answer all of
those questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history
country for entrepreneurs.
Now in another visual politic video,
we told you how a silicon valley startup
gets financed.
We talked about the so called startup
financing cycle.
And of course silicon valley is the best
place on earth to find people ready to
bat on your idea as another bonus.
This place is the Disneyland of skilled
workforces.
If you want to start a company that
manufactures self driving cars,
you need people who've mastered the
latest technology
drinks.
And the reality is you ain't gonna find
them in the middle of Wyoming.
The most talented people they gather in
Silicon Valley and they're ready to hire
or get hired.
So well,
what's the problem?
Well,
these tons of people you would like to
hire for your brand new startup and now
do busy earning $150,000 a year at
Google.
And yeah,
your idea,
it might be disruptive and it might be
innovative,
but yet can't compete with the salaries
and especially the stability that a
giant like a Google can provide,
right?
Snap
a startup in a garage with the garage
costs millions of dollars.
Odd.
Jay Ryan from Mithril capital talking to
the economist,
but this isn't the end of the story.
Remember,
California has the highest taxes in the
entire United States and things.
They don't just stop that.
You see in America,
states have plenty of autonomy to raise
or lower taxes and can even decide how
they want to collect those taxes.
For example,
the state of taxes,
it doesn't have an income tax.
Most of the taxes they collect the
through in direct taxation,
there's all the taxes that you pay on
top of the things you buy.
California,
they're the opposite.
They're very little value added tax and
most of the collection comes from
workers' salaries and especially capital
gains.
In other words,
if you're an investor and you're making
a loss of money this year,
you had better get your wallet ready
because California is going to charge
you more than anywhere else and this,
this is not exactly great news when you
consider that silicon valley is what it
is because of venture capitalists.
Nonetheless,
this is not the only reason why people
are leaving the valley.
For example,
Peter Teal hasn't left because of state
taxes,
otherwise he wouldn't have gone to Los
Angeles,
which is in California.
The truth is that a lot of people like
believe that Silicon Valley has lost all
of the diversity that it used to be
famous.
Hello,
Peter Teal.
Silicon Valley has become a one party
state.
Basically,
Peter Teal supported Donald Trump during
the campaign and apparently this kind of
thing is not very well regarded in the
valley where liberal thinking as King
Allen's well,
truth be told,
there are many reasons why silicon
valley people are not big fans of Donald
Trump and well,
that's explore those reasons.
Speed
One b
June.
When I told you that the greatest amount
of talent on the planet is located in
Silicon Valley.
Well,
I didn't misspeak.
I did mean planet and not just America.
This means that 57% of the people
working for the tech companies in the
valley come from other countries.
Yes,
this is an industry with more immigrants
on the locals and well,
how do these immigrants get into
America?
Well,
that's easy.
They use the famous h one b visa.
Basically,
this is a visa that allows you to stay
on US territory for between three and
six.
Cheers,
get it.
You must be hired by a company that can
prove that your skills are both
necessary to its operations and that
those skills cannot be provided by
domestic work
groups
fired.
You have one month to find another job.
You can't find another job.
You must leave America.
Of course,
this visa is requested by the employer
and the government can deny it if they
want to.
And most importantly,
these visas are limited.
They can issue a maximum of 65,000 in
the entire country.
As you can imagine.
A good share of them.
Go to those workers.
Emigrating to silicon valley for a
better understanding.
Justin,
the year 2016 google and apple hides
more than 5,000 people through this
process and of course you can probably
work out what I'm going to say next.
Donald Trump ain't exactly a fan of the
h one b
trump's hire American order.
It makes it harder to get h one b visas.
No,
I don't know about you,
but backwards.
Donald Trump took office.
We made a video where we explained all
of the powers that the president has,
these other things that he can do
without having to get a vote in
Congress.
Border control is one of them and if you
saw that video,
which is actually one of the first we
ever made on this channel,
you will remember Obama was just as
restrictive on immigration as Donald
Trump us.
The devil here is very much in the
details and one of the details is this h
one b visa.
It's in fact a very small detail that
makes a big problem in silicon.
Holly Silicon Valley's
stalls.
Hiring a foreign tech workers,
employer requests to interview
candidates fall 37% on trump immigration
fears
according to some media.
Many of these tech companies might open
new offices in countries like Canada
where it's easier to hire immigrants,
but so far we don't have any data as to
whether this is actually happening or if
it's ever really going to happen on the
last,
the question we can already start
answering is this were good.
The next tech capital of the welds be,
well,
we're going to tell you right now from
Palo Alto to shenzen,
if you google it,
you'll discover that almost every city
wants to become the new silicon valley.
You just need to find a journalist who
finds a couple of computer programmers
working together and you've already got
an article titled the Silicon Valley of
Insert name of your city or region.
Yeah.
For example,
there are lots of wishful articles that
quoted Berlin as a startup creation hub.
Even the German government is open to
offices in silicon valley so that German
entrepreneurs can find investors.
But the truth is that almost no company
has managed to seduce those big venture
capital funds in California at least.
So the big question now is how do we
know if a city is really becoming a
technological capital?
Well,
one way of measuring this would be the
number of Unicorns that have been born
yet and say now might be asking,
well,
what's a unicorn beside,
of course,
the mythical beast.
Well,
a Unicorn is a startup that ends up with
a valuation of over $1 billion.
In 2017 57 startups became unicorns and
from those 57 startups,
18 we're not American.
In fact,
China was their country of origin.
Yes,
he was.
We're talking about companies like Dji,
which manufacturers,
drones and Alibaba,
which we talked about here on visual
politic previously,
and it explains headlines like this one
in this latest growth market.
Yes.
Venture capital,
for example,
sequoia capital.
There's a vc fund to born in Silicon
Valley.
They have already opened several offices
in China and I know what you're
thinking.
Does this really mean that China is
going to mouth shine America?
Well,
the answer is no.
Other cities like Mumbai in India and
Tel Aviv in Israel have also attracted a
lot of money from VC funds.
You might've heard of a company called a
wix.
This is a company that allows you to
create websites very easily.
Well,
they're from Israel,
knew the
country,
has no Unicorns,
is real,
does have more than 2% of all of the
worlds of capital.
That might not seem like a lot of money,
but it is if we take into account the
fact that Israel has a smaller
population than New York
Si.
In summary,
there is no clear alternative to silicon
valley.
Even now with the accidents we talked
about,
silicon valley still gets more than half
of the money that's invested into
startups and chances are they're going
to continue to hold that sway over this
industry for a long time.
So what's the difference then?
Well,
now there aren't many other places where
good ideas can prospect.
In other words,
30 years ago,
if you had a good idea and you wanted to
see it grow,
there was virtually one place to go.
Now you've got many more in,
well this is always good news.
So now the question is,
do you think silicon valley has reached
its peak in terms of growth or do you
believe this accidents will stop soon
and that the valley will start growing
again?
Well,
please leave your arms in the comments
section below.
I'll say visit,
reconsider media.com the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode,
but when our mind,
and as always,
don't forget,
we published brand new videos every
week.
So subscribe to visual politic and hit
that bell button so you won't miss any
posts or so.
If you like this video,
give us a thumbs up.
And as always I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
I'll forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com and we
consider it as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context.
But we don't do the thinking.